Ooh, look at this hotel room that I can't wait to stain up.
I have this medical condition where
I have forever grubby fingers.
My heritage is English, Irish, German, and Trash Monster.
Hi guys, my name is Grace Helbig.
If you did not know, now you know. Your life is different now.
It's a stream of consciousness vlog today, and
because I'm in Cannes, France.
Wanna see it? Okay
Look at this beautiful view.
Whoa
That's France ya'll.
Cannes you see it?
I hate myself.
And we're back.
When I do natural lighting for videos, my eye makeup,
there's always like a shading--
[Sound of water splashing]
Is there a room next door with the biggest water bed of all time?
France!
Anytime I use natural light, it always looks really great,
but then the shading--
[Sound of water splashing again]
There might be a water park in the room next door. I'm not sure.
France!
I swear I put an equal amount of eye makeup on,
but a lot of times you guys like to comment on the fact that one eye
looks like it's got more makeup than the other eye.
And it's because my eyes are crooked.
If any of you follow me on social media,
you might have gotten some hints into how--
I think there might be a school of clowns
working in the room next door on their pratfalls.
I don't know. France!
If any of you follow me on social media,
you know that my journey to get to France was not easy.
Let me walk you through it.
Story time! Is this a story time video?
I'm not Gigi Gorgeous but I wish I just had a little
bit of her essence.
France!
So last week, I took a friend to Medieval times because they'd never been before
And I lost a bet and I-- The consequence was, I had to
um, take a friend on an adventure time. And so Medieval Times.
And yes, I did post a video not long ago of going to
Medieval Times in New Jersey for my mom's 60th birthday.
Going to 2 different Medieval Times on 2 different coasts in the United states
in two weeks is not sad, 'cause it's not 3 times.
Though I wasn't turning up to a Youtube event
after Medieval Times with my mom
and the event in Toronto was directly next to
the Medieval TImes in Toronto so...
But I didn't go.
So I have self control.
Only in the going to Medieval Times in my life,
everything else in my life I'm just a
*weird crab hands*
crab the consumer.
Went to Medieval Times,
had a great time,
mind was lost,
reality blown,
fun times had.
Then went to a restaurant across the street
to have some drinks after the show.
Had a bunch of drinks.
The restaurant was closing,
we took an Uber back at like 12:30 at night to Los Angeles.
Made it back totally fine.
Wake up the next morning,
did a conference call,
I had a car coming to pick me up
at 12:30 to take me to the airport
and take Mamrie to the airport.
The car was supposed to take me and then pick up Mamrie
cuz she was coming as my plus one
to this Cannes excursion.
And we were supposed to go to the airport.
I start packing, everything's going well.
I'm packing clothes that kind of make sense
for the first time in my packing career.
Spoiler alert, they don't.
I'm here, I went to Zara 5 minutes ago
because I don't pack correctly.
Even when I think I am.
It's like 12:20,
the car driver rings my doorbell, says he's here.
I say I'll just be another 10 minutes,
don't worry, I'm packing everything up,
just finalizing getting my tech and all this kind of stuff.
Then I pick up my backpack that I had with me at Medieval Times,
I open it to transfer the stuff in that backpack
to my travel backpack.
And everything is there except for
my f*cking wallet.
I'm an extremist,
I either live on
slightly sad, distracted, a little depressed, procrastinating street.
Or wild, reckless, messy, impulsive, irresponsible street.
I don't spend much time in between these streets.
But I do spend an awful amount of time playing an invisible accordion.
I'm very good.
I pack my wallet on irresponsible street.
I put every single thing, my passport, my medical cards,
my SAG actor card, my credit cards, my ID license, my passport card.
Every thing that's important to me in that wallet.
So when I have it on me I have everything I could
possibly need and I don't forget anything.
But when I lose it I lose everything.
So I start frantically looking for my wallet,
I can't find it anywhere.
I call my friend who was with me the night before,
he doesn't have it, he calls the restaurant,
they say they don't have it.
I'm trying to get in touch with Uber,
which by the way if you ever tried to get in touch with Uber,
it's like putting a watermelon up your butt hole,
it's very, very
almost impossible.
They make it impossible for you to call them.
A lot like me.
So I'm spending forever trying to figure out how to
get in touch with my Uber driver,
which was so difficult.
And makes me understand how people must feel when they want to
contact me about important business related things.
I'm sorry business related humans in my life.
Karma.
I talked to Mamrie letting her know that I can't find my wallet,
I don't know what to do.
The car's out front,
I talk to my agent, same thing,
I don't know what to do.
But I do know how to cry though
so I'm doing that very well at this point.
Mamrie ends up going to an Uber and going to the airport,
just in case I find my wallet and I'm able to meet her there.
I call the restaurant again just to see if someone else
would answer, maybe knew more about the wallet.
They say no.
Cut to
the sad realization that the wallet is
gone.
And this is not a shining moment,
I mean none of this has been a shining moment,
but this particularly I was so depressed
I didn't know what to do
I just started slamming red wine at noon.
That is not the way to handle your problems.
I don't even normally drink red wine
it's just there and that made it even worse.
So I was just like wallowing and washing myself in pity,
and sadness, and guilty, and irresponsible
and that's always a fun metaphorical shower.
And the only shower that I had had in like three days.
Mamrie ends up going to the airport but you have to
check in 2 hours before an international flight
so she misses her flight.
They can't find more flights for her
she ends up having to take another hour and a half Uber
back to her house because she couldn't come with me.
Which sucks.
And I'm still very sorry Mamrie
I owe you very many cocktails at very many bars.
I will live up to my word.
Once I get new credit cards
because
they're all gone.
So I ended up having to go to the federal building
the next day and wait there
ALL
DAMN
DAY
to get a same day passport to try and get on a flight at 7:15
And I actually met some of you guys there
at the federal building also getting a passport.
Not my ideal setting to have you meet me
but thank you for saying hi
you all were very nice and I hope you all got your passports.
It took me a very long time to get mine.
Line after line
after line after line.
I mean it was like a coke den
there were so many lines.
That's not a good metaphor.
It was like Disneyland, so many lines.
Family friendly entertainment here.
However
I got a new passport.
That's not the face of a psychopath that would definitely
lose her wallet with all of her important possessions
the morning before an international flight
to an event that has already been internationally publicized.
No way!
This is a responsible-
human.
You too can get photos like that at a Fed Ex
right near the federal building in Los Angeles.
And the karma continued a little bit 'cause
I had a connecting flight in Frankfurt
so I flew from Los Angeles to Frankfurt and then Frankfurt to Nice.
And on my first flight that was like 10 or 11 hours,
I had a middle seat which gives me anxiety
if I don't travel with someone I know on either end.
And also
the US Mens Polo team was on the flight.
So just like 6 ft 4 to 6 ft 6 Clydesdale-esque human men
scattered throughout the plane one in which sat
directly in front of me and decided that he needs to have
his seat reclined the entire 10 to 11 hours so
*deep sigh*
I deserved it.
If any of you out there have my wallet
go f*ck yourselves.
I mean
I should be more responsible.
Well I guess that's it for this video
this was supposed to be a stream of consciousness
but it's just a story time.
Look at me, I did a story time.
*gasp*
Am I participating in YouTube trends?
Not for long
If you guys liked this video and you like
story time videos from me, give this video a thumbs up.
I don't do these very often
but maybe I should. Let me know,
leave a comment down below.
And subscribe to this YouTube channel, hit the subscribe button,
I make videos Monday, Wednesday and Friday.
Sometimes.
Unless I lose my wallet and have to spend all day
crying in shame and then
standing at the federal building.
You know, it happens to the best of us.
No it doesn't.
I don't know.
And I'm here in Cannes for Cannes Lions
which is this advertising and marketing festival
that I've been to a couple years ago.
I actually got to speak on stage yesterday with Laura Dern
about tradiational vs new media and marketing
and how that all fits together
and she is an absolute wonderful angel human being.
Like I want her to know that I like her but I don't want her
to watch the beginning part of this video in which
I very much admit how
awful and incapable of a fraggle trash human I am.
Cuz I don't want her to have that impression of me.